y
[Música]
muy muy sal y sal para hacer un largo
viaje
con tan solo 15 años decidió exiliarse
[Música]
hoy el aeropuerto por favor
sola sin sus padres la adolescente va a
abandonar hong kong
y no se trata de un viaje como cualquier
otro está huyendo
y se va para escapar de la justicia de
hong kong
por su participación en el movimiento
prodemocracia podría recibir una pena de
hasta cinco años de prisión
estoy triste me voy un poco obligada
espero poder volver a hong kong algún
día para nosotros la joven generación el
futuro es sombrío creo que como opositor
al gobierno no tengo ningún futuro aquí
podría ser enviado a prisión
creo que teniendo en cuenta el contexto
no tengo otra opción que irme si quiero
ofrecerme un mejor futuro
[Música]
una nueva vida le espera al final del
trayecto muy muy se va a inglaterra
[Música]
londres se volvió la referencia de
aquellos que huyen de hong kong desde el
inicio de año más de 27.000 hongkoneses
han radicado una solicitud de visa en la
antigua potencia colonial cuentan con un
estatus particular que les permite
instalarse durante cinco años y obtener
finalmente la nacionalidad británica
entre los que han encontrado refugio
aquí
muchos manifestantes que quieren huir de
los procesos tal como este joven de 21
años desde el movimiento prodemocracia
cuenta con un alias
malcolm
porque me hago llamar mal como un
homenaje a malcolm x
para mí si se quiere vencer al partido
comunista china y todos los medios son
válidos hay que intentarlo todo nace
sobre whale
en hong kong mal con lideraba un grupo
de manifestantes acostumbrados a
enfrentarse a la policía
fue uno de los primeros en llegar a
inglaterra
aquí fundó una asociación que les ayuda
a los que desean huir de la antigua
colonia británica
[Música]
los hongkoneses deben ayudarse los unos
a los otros tenemos la responsabilidad y
el deber de apoyar a los que nos
contactan para pedirnos ayuda desde hace
un año malcolm ha ayudado a unos 60
manifestantes para que lleguen al reino
unido
esta noche se dirige a blackburn en el
norte de inglaterra
fue ahí donde instaló la sede de su
asociación financiada por ricos donantes
hongkoneses
esta es nuestra sede en black
aquí tenemos otra en londres y en un
futuro contaremos con otras locales
es desde este apartamento que malcolm
organizó y financió el aura de la joven
manifestante de 15 años
va a poder verla por teléfono por
primera vez desde que llegó a londres
hola hola
y cómo estás
de llegar irás encontrando tu lugar a su
llegada al aeropuerto muy ridícula
solicitud de asilo político en la medida
en que es menor de edad fue ubicada en
una familia inglesa de acogida
si pudiese estar con ustedes la
situación sería distinta estaríamos
entre hong kong ellos me sentiría mejor
mira aquí la gente no me entiende
dijo que no están de acuerdo con mi
decisión
dicen que era muy joven para oír que
debería escuchar a los adultos de hoy o
ella consigo hania o
en ese apartamento vive en una decena de
antiguos manifestantes que tal como muy
muy eligieron a abandonar hong kong
entre estos exiliados algunos apoyan
abiertamente la independencia de su
territorio debido a esta postura en hong
kong serían enviados a prisión entonces
frente a nuestras cámaras se expresan
anónimamente
vinieron a reunido para reencontrarse
con las libertades que les quito
de centro
alten creo que hong kong tal como lo
conocíamos está muriendo
y creo que el partido comunista chino
está tratando de tomar el control de
hong kong un control total a internet
las libertades individuales las
libertades de manifestar escribir
asamblea fueron of arts inc
desde hace un año los hongkoneses viven
bajo la amenaza de una nueva ley dictada
por beijing la excusa de regresar a la
calma y a la estabilidad tras las
manifestaciones prodemocracia del verano
de 2019
este texto permite procesar a todos los
que no le tengan lealtad al china
en la antigua colonia británica los
arrestos y las condenas se multiplican
en los círculos de la oposición
[Música]
sí
la juventud con con esta que participo
en los diferentes movimientos de
protesta ahora vive en suspenso
para escapar de esta amenaza muy muy
decidió huir unas cuantas horas antes de
irse a inglaterra la joven no recibió en
esta habitación de hotel en su maleta se
llevó algunos recuerdos de su compromiso
a favor de la democracia
[Música]
es una camiseta negra muy sencilla
pregunta mucho para mí porque es la que
llevaba puesta durante las
manifestaciones en cuanto salí a la
calle me la pone a todos estábamos
vestidos de negro para mezclarnos y no
ser identificables muy muy se
comprometió como un militante en junio
de 2019
durante todo el verano tal como cientos
de miles de hongkoneses se manifestó a
favor de la democracia y contra la pena
fascina
pero un año más tarde fue detenida por
la policía
estaba con mis amigos y cantábamos
slogans prodemocracia en un centro
comercial de repente la policía nos
rodeó y nos detuvo a hablar con fue
procesada por participación en una
reunión ilegal
jajajajajaja
tal como muy muy más de 1700 menores
fueron detenidos desde las
manifestaciones de 2019
entre ellos cerca de 500 ya fueron
condenados yéndose inglaterra la joven
evitó un proceso pero hizo una lección
radical
con tan solo 15 años abandonó a sus
padres proxy na
no saben nada sobre su inminente partida
[Música]
no le dije nada a mi padre y a los otros
miembros de mi familia les pido perdón
pero espero que algún día entiendan por
qué lo hice
soy el jockey de jazz williams
aquella noche vino a despedirse de su
primo en la bahía de hong kong el único
miembro de su familia al tanto de sus
proyectos él también es un manifestante
prodemocracia desea permanecer en el
anonimato y deplora la elección de muy
muy
creo que esta situación es terrible
la ciudad debería estar feliz estuviera
en el colegio salir con amigas hacer
compras en lugar de ello es obligada a
abandonar hong kong
una juventud que huye que sueña con que
reinó unido- sea la tribuna de su lucha
soy night and love una activista hong
kong es que huyó a londres conmigo en
este set el antiguo diputado junto en
ese y activista prodemocracia en la tan
lona tan bienvenido refugiado en londres
uno de los más célebres militantes
prodemocracia natal lo hace una
seguidilla de entrevistas en televisión
para alertar al mundo occidental sobre
la disminución de libertades en hong
kong
soy consciente de tener una enorme
responsabilidad estando aquí y cada vez
que tenga la oportunidad seré el
portavoz de hong kong ahora estoy aquí y
hablo para el pueblo hong kong es y
luchó por nuestras libertades y la
democracia
en las calles de la capital británica
tenemos cita con el joven de 27 años un
año después de haber abandonado hong
kong natal lo saborea poder defender
aquí libremente sus ideas
si me hubiese quedado estaría en prisión
soy un fugitivo buscado por la policía
hongkonesa porque se me acusa de
corrupción con fuerzas extranjeras de
secesionismo ello muestra a qué punto el
gobierno quiere perseguir a cada
activista prodemocracia en hong kong de
hecho estamos todos en presión o
procesados o en el exilio
incluso a cerca de 10.000 kilómetros de
su casa a pesar de su exilio natal no
quiere continuar su lucha no creo que
quiera decir que fracasamos significa
que el movimiento entró en una nueva
fase la persecución política es muy
fuerte en este momento y es por ello que
muchos de nosotros tuvimos que abandonar
hong kong pero estoy convencido de que
continuaremos luchando por hong kong no
abandonaremos la lucha
muy muy mal con natalio y todos los que
eligieron el exilio no saben si volverán
algún día a hong kong reino unido espera
una llegada masiva de ciudadanos hong
kong es es la oficina de inmigración
considera que serán más de 300.000 los
que se instalarán aquí durante los
próximos cinco años